-Keira, welcome back to the --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, they love you.
-Wow!
Hey!
-Yes!
-Look -- people.
-People.
Isn't that nice?
Isn't it the greatest thing
in the world.
The best audience ever.
-Yeah, people are great.
Yep.
-Yeah.
You look fantastic.
How are you doing?
How is the family?
-The family are okay.
-Yeah, they're good, yeah.
-You know, they're --
Yeah, they're okay.
-How old are they now --
the kids?
-3 and 7.
-Love it.
-Yeah, they were trying to --
They're not happy about me
being here.
-They're not?
-No.
I said,
"I've got to go to New York."
They said, "Why?" I said, "Well,
I'm gonna be on television."
And my 3-year-old
doesn't get that.
My 3-year-old is like,
"In da television?"
[ Laughter ]
And I'm like, "Yes."
And she's like, "But how do you
get in da television?"
"Well, I get -- in New York,
I get in the television."
But, you know -- so, but --
-Yeah, it's a camera.
Yeah, you can't explain.
-Yeah, the whole camera thing --
They couldn't explain.
-No.
What are they into right now?
-Oh, rainbow unicorns.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Rainbow unicorns.
-Everything.
Everything rainbow unicorns.
-I had a feeling that you would
say that they're into that.
-Yeah.
-Would you like to --
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-Oh, look.
-Just in case --
-Shall I, for her?
Because she did actually
say to me --
she said, "If you are going
in the television,
you have to be dressed
like rainbow unicorn."
And I was like, "Well, I'm not
gonna do that, obviously."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
Yes!
-So, yes.
-Mom of the Year!
-Mum of the Year.
-Your mom loves you so much!
-Right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Delilah Belle Righton,
I love you.
Can I take it off now?
-Yes. Yeah, of course.
Yes, of course.
[ Laughter ]
It was just for your daughter.
-Thank you, thank you.
I appreciate that.
-Do they understand
why you're in "da television"?
-I mean, yeah,
I've tried to explain films.
Actually, they've seen
one of the --
I did a version of
"The Nutcracker" a few years ago
where I play, like,
a psychotic pink cake.
And so --
And so, they watched that.
-Wow.
-Yeah, but she didn't
like that at all.
She was like,
"A, you should be dressed
in rainbows."
And she was,
"Why are you so angry?"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "I don't know."
And then the other one,
I tried to show her
"Pirates of the Caribbean."
She watched 10 minutes.
She was far too terrified.
She said, "I don't --
I don't want to see you
doing that."
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Yeah, she wasn't impressed.
But do you know
what she also said?
She said,
"No, I don't like you in that.
You're too pretty."
I was like, "Oh."
But she said, "But don't worry,
you're not anymore."
[ Audience "Ohhs" ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Wow!
Brutal.
-"Mwah! Go to sleep,
go to sleep." Right?
-Yeah, "I love you, I love you."
-Yeah.
"You were cute for a second."
-Yeah, exactly.
-Have any of them
shown any interest in acting?
-No. No.
I actually asked her.
I said, "You know, do --
You know, is that something --"
We took her to the theater.
I said, "Is that something
that you want to do?"
She was like, "No!"
I went, "Why not?"
Said, "All those people
were looking at you!"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"You know, I'm quite proud."
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah, good.
Don't get involved.
-"Good point."
-Yeah.
-You started acting at around
7 years old, right?
-I did -- 6, yes.
-6. In something called, I want
to say, "Royal Celebration"?
-It was. It was called
"A Royal Celebration."
I don't think I did very much.
I think I sort of ran in
and said, "Mummy, Daddy."
You know, but I loved it.
-Did you have any -- "Mommy,
Daddy," were your lines?
-I mean, I don't remember.
I remember very few lines.
I remember there being,
you know, there were marks
on the floor where you have
to hit when you're acting on --
on -- on film,
and I remember mine was green,
and I was so pleased
about hitting my mark
and just being there.
-And it was about
Princess Diana and Charles?
-It was about a street party
on the day
that Charles and Diana
got married.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-This was your acting debut?
-This was my acting debut, yeah.
-We found the clip.
We have it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Your acting debut.
-No.
-And you did have a line.
-Did I?
-Yeah. Here is 6-year-old
Keira Knightley
making her acting debut
in "Royal Celebration."
Check this out.
-...their new life together.
-Here, here, here, here!
-Everybody's been waiting for.
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow, yeah.
I mean, I had one word,
which I repeated many times.
So, I clearly -- I milked it.
Yeah.
-"Here, here, here, here!"
-Yeah.
-And then smash cut to --
totally different.
-Glum.
-You got your one line over.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Out.
-Just -- We were looking at IMDb
today, and just 20 years,
almost to the day,
was the release of
"Bend It Like Beckham."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Isn't that crazy?
I feel like just yesterday
you did that film.
Did you know that it was
gonna be a giant hit?
Or did you feel like it was
going to be your breakout?
-No. No, no, I mean, I literally
remember telling people
that I was doing it
and saying, you know,
"It's called
'Bend It Like Beckham,'"
and them going, "Oh,
that's really embarrassing."
[ Laughter ]
-Really?
-Okay. Yeah, yeah.
No, it was -- no. And they were
all like, "Don't worry.
Nobody will see it.
It's fine."
-"Don't worry.
Nobody will see it."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, it was --
No, but it was the idea of it,
because you know women's soccer
was not as big back then.
-Yeah.
-And so, the idea of the whole
thing was sort of ridiculous.
And it's amazing, because it's
still the film, even today,
you know, if somebody comes up
and talks to me about my work,
it's that one.
It's so loved.
-Yeah.
-It's like -- it's amazing.
-Yeah, it is beloved.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You've done some great work,
though.
-Thank you.
-I want to talk about
your new one,
"Boston Strangler."
It's out on Hulu this Friday.
It's based on the true story.
How much about the story
did you know?
-I didn't really know very much.
So, I'd obviously heard of it.
-Yeah.
-So -- but really,
I just sort of read the script
and thought, "Whoa.
This is such
a complicated story.
And so interesting."
And what I didn't realize
was that there are
these two female journalists
right at the center
of the story.
And actually,
when you google it, you know,
they were the two that really
kind of went after it.
They first linked the killings.
They even named the killer
"The Boston Strangler."
And yet, when you google it,
their kind of part of
that history
has largely been erased.
So, it felt like
a really interesting --
You know, it's a true-crime --
crime piece.
It felt -- It felt cool to
kind of see it through that
female gaze
and to put these two journalists
sort of in the center of it.
-And it's shot in Boston.
And, yeah.
Did you do a Boston accent?
-No.
-That's a smart move.
-Well, I wanted to do
the Boston accent.
-[ Laughs ]
-Who talked you out?
-The director was like,
"Abso--" He's from Boston.
-Oh, yeah.
No, people from Boston --
-No. You can't --
I mean, if you weren't
from the street that the
character was from in Boston,
you were not allowed
to do the Boston accent.
So every single actor
went in going, "Boston accent!
It's our time!"
-You're like, "No, no, no, no!
No, but everyone's
made this mistake!"
-Yeah, yeah, no,
we were not allowed.
So it's a standard
American accent.
[ Laughter ]
There is no Boston.
-That is a very smart move
that you did that.
I was in a Boston movie.
I did not do a Boston accent,
but I did do it
when my character got excited.
Like rea--
-Yeah. You've got it in there?
-Oh, yeah.
-Really?
-If my character was drunk
or excited, I threw a Boston.
-You threw it. And nobody went,
"You're not allowed"?
-No, it worked.
It was perfect.
I actually was yelling it.
Because Boston,
you can't mess it up.
-No, you can't.
-And it lives forever.
And they'll find you
on the streets and be like,
"That accent was terrible."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're very vocal about it.
-Yelling from the windows of
Dunkin' Donuts at you.
Yeah, absolutely.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's Keira Knightley in
"Boston Strangler."
Take a look.
-They won't coordinate
with other police departments.
Connections are being missed,
and good leads are falling
through the cracks.
-Isn't some of that
to be expected?
-We are way beyond that.
Oh, I'm sorry, Jack.
Am I keeping you up?
-Will you cut the [bleep]
already?
What's the story?
-The city can't protect
its women.
-Come on.
-What?
You don't think it's true, or
you don't think it's a story?
-What the hell is it with you?
You can't go after
someone's livelihood
because you're impatient.
-10 women are dead,
and these [bleep]
don't have a clue.
-You don't have a story.
You have a grudge.
-How many women have to die
before it's a story?
-That's enough.
These are good men
busting their asses.
I'm not waging a war
on the police department.
-Yeah.
Keira Knightley, everybody.
"Boston Strangler" is available
on Hulu this Friday.
Zachary Levi joins us
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.